so I have two curves graphed here and
we're used to seeing things where Y is a
function of X but here we have X as a
function of Y in fact we can write this
top expression as being a function of Y
and the second one just to make it
different we could view this as G of Y
once again it is a function of Y and
what we're concerning ourselves with in
this video is how do we find this area
in this light blue color between these
two curves and I encourage you to pause
the video and try to work through it
alright so a huge hint here is we're
going to want to integrate with respect
to Y a definite integral where our
bounds are in terms of Y so for example
this is this lower point of intersection
right over here this would be our lower
bound in terms of Y let's call that y1
and then this up here this would be our
upper Y bound so if we think about where
do these two curves intersect and we
look at the Y coordinates of those
intersections well that gives us two
nice bounds for our integral so we're
gonna take our integral from y1 to y2
from y1 to y2 y2 we're going to
integrate with respect to Y dy and so
what are we going to sum up well when we
integrate we can think about taking the
sum of infinitely thin rectangles and in
this case it would be infinitely flat
rectangle since we're thinking about D Y
so dy would be the height of each of
these rectangles and what would be in
this case the width or the length of
this rectangle right over here well over
this interval from y1 to y2 our blue
function f of Y it takes on larger
x-values than G of Y so this length
right over here this would be F of Y F
of Y this x value minus this x value
minus G of Y so this is going to be f of
Y
- G of Y G of Y well we know what F of Y
and G of Y are really the trickiest part
is is figuring out these points of
intersection so let's think about where
these two curves intersect they are both
equal to X so we can set these two Y
expressions equal to each other so we
know that negative let me do it in that
other color so we know that negative y
squared plus 3y plus 11 is going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to y
squared plus y minus 1 so let's just
subtract all of this from both sides so
then on the right side we have a zero
and on the left side we just have a
quadratic so let's subtract Y squared
let's subtract Y and then subtract
negative 1 which is just adding one is
and then over here we're going to do the
same thing - y plus one and what we are
left with is going to be as hopefully a
straightforward quadratic so let's see
this is going to be negative 2y squared
plus two why am i doing that right yeah
plus 2y plus 12 is equal to zero and
then this over here I can factor out a
negative two and I get negative two
times y squared minus y minus six is
equal to zero this we can factor from
inspection what two numbers when we add
equal negative 1 when we take the
product we get negative 6 well that
would be negative 3 and 2 so this is
going to be negative 2 times y minus 3
times y plus 2 this is straightforward
factoring a polynomial or quadratic do I
do that right yep that looks right is
equal to 0 so what are the points of
intersection the points of intersection
are going to be Y is equal to 3 and Y is
equal to negative 2
so this right over here is y is equal to
negative two and then the upper bound is
y is equal to three so now we just have
to evaluate this from negative two all
the way until three so let's do that I'm
going to clear this out so I get a
little bit of real estate so this is
equal to the integral from negative two
to three of negative Y squared plus 3y
plus eleven minus all of this stuff so
if we just distribute a negative sign
here it's minus y squared minus y plus
one and then we have a dy D Y this is
equal to the definite integral from
negative 2 to positive 3 of let's see
negative y squared minus y squared
negative 2y squared and then 3y minus y
is going to be plus 2y and then 11 plus
1 plus well we saw this just now we were
trying to solve for y dy and so what is
that going to be equal to well we just
take the antiderivative here this is
going to be let's see negative 2 let's
increment the exponent Y does they're
divided by that exponent reverse power
rule plus 2 y squared divided by 2 which
is just Y squared just the reverse power
rule and then plus 12y and we're going
to evaluate that at 3 and at negative 2
so if we evaluate that at 3 we are going
to get 2 negative 2 times 27 over 3 plus
9 plus 36 and then we are going to want
to subtract minus all of this evaluated
negative 2 so it's going to be negative
2 times negative 8 over 3 plus
for minus 24 so we just had a little bit
of mathematics ahead of us so let's see
this is going to be 27 divided by 3 is 9
so this is negative 18 negative 18 plus
9 is going to be negative 9 plus 36 all
of that is going to be equal to so the
stuff in blue is equal to 27 all right
did I do that right yet negative 18 plus
9 yep 27 and then all the stuff in red
over here we have this is going to be
negative times a negative so it's 16
over 3 plus 4 minus 24 so that is going
to be 16 over 3 and then minus minus 20
minus 20 but then we have this negative
out here so it's if we distribute that
we'll get plus 20 minus we could say
instead of 16 over 3 we could rewrite
that as 5 and 1/3 minus 5 and 1/3 and so
what is that going to get us let me
scroll down a little bit let me go to
the right so I have a little bit more
real estate here so then that is going
to be equal to you get a minor drumroll
here 47 minus 5 minus 1/3 which is equal
to let's see 47 minus 5 that's 42 minus
1/3 is now we get a drumroll
41 and 2/3 and we are done